tucker carlson this week in a completely
confused and nonsensical
monologue that maybe uh
said that maybe the reason coveted
precautions are still in place in some
states now remember some states have
eliminated all covet guidelines
but tucker says we have vaccines now
if we still have covet precautions in
some states
maybe the vaccines don't actually work
this is tucker take a look at the clip
the federal health authorities also
recommend that you continue to wear your
mask when you go outside
how long will this continue well
according to yahoo news experts say it's
quote
not entirely clear when it will be
considered okay for people
who are fully vaccinated to stop wearing
masks
at some point no one's asking this but
everyone should be what is this
about if vaccines work
why are vaccinated people still banned
from living normal lives honestly what's
the answer to that it doesn't make any
sense at all if the vaccine is effective
there is no reason for people who have
received the vaccine
to wear masks or avoid physical contact
so maybe it doesn't work and they're
simply not telling you
that well you hate to think that
especially if you've gotten
two shots but what's the other potential
explanation we can't think of one
we know the prime minister of canada has
decided after thinking about it a lot
that vaccines just don't work and we
know that because he said it out loud
now there is a lot to say about that and
and i'm going to say it
in a little bit but in response to that
segment
dr anthony fauci appeared on cnn and
was asked about it and he slammed it
as a typical crazy conspiracy theory
take a listen to this that's just a
typical crazy conspiracy theory
why would we not tell people if it
doesn't work look at the data
the data are overwhelming in the three
vaccines that have been approved for
use in an emergency use authorization
the jnj
the pfizer and the moderna
you had thirty thousand forty four
thousand and forty thousand people in a
clinical trial
with an overwhelming signal of efficacy
so i don't have any idea what he's
talking about
so i don't actually know the best way to
deal with this quite frankly because um
if you believe tucker when tucker says
maybe the vaccines don't work does dr
fauci
going on cnn and calling it a conspiracy
theory
change your mind like if you're in the
um under the umbrella of people
who believe tucker when he says it or
does it just reinforce your belief
now there is an answer there is an
explanation and it's really very simple
we have vaccines that work really well
they are over 90 effective at preventing
infection
they are almost 100 percent effective at
preventing
serious illness and death there's one
amazing study
of 700 000 vaccinated people somewhere
on the west coast i don't remember
if it was washington or oregon 700 000
vaccinated people were followed
about a hundred got the virus that's
point
zero one four percent
point zero one four four percent of the
vaccinated group got the virus
three people died that's four point 4.28
times 10 to the negative fourth power
go back to middle school math
to realize how tiny a number that is
these are
extraordinarily effective vaccines so
why do why does anybody need precautions
why do we need any masks why do we need
anything
because as of april 13th only 37 of the
country was vaccinated
it's that simple you know the the when
what we've seen
from israel is that when you get to at
least
50 55 fully vaccinated
then you start to see cases go down very
very quickly
and so if on the first day of
vaccination
you open everything you don't have
enough protection
tons of people will get the virus and
many of them will die what's really
amazing
about what tucker does is he brings up
questions that have really simple
answers
but he pretends that they are profound
and incisive questions and his audience
sees it and says wow yeah
i mean if the vaccines work why do we
have any precautions
since we have vaccines and precautions
maybe the vaccine doesn't actually work
well no
the answer is really simple barely a
third of the country has been vaccinated
that's it that's the answer and
sometimes the answer
being so simple actually uh
makes it more difficult to explain it or
convince people because people
don't want to believe that they might
not understand such a simple answer
many people when presented with the
question we have vaccines but we have
guidelines
maybe the vaccines don't work maybe
there's this this is a lie or that's a
lie no
we just haven't vaccinated enough people
lots of people don't want to believe
about themselves
that they could have missed such a
simple
basic rudimentary answer look at the
numbers in israel
israel is now highly vaccinated they
have about 200 cases a day
israel and new jersey have basically the
same population
size they're both around 9 million new
jersey has 4
000 cases per day i'm going to say that
again because it's it's so incredible
israel and new jersey are about the same
size
and they're about the same population
new jersey has
4 000 cases per day
israel has 200. what's the difference
the difference
is new jersey is only 26 percent fully
vaccinated
whereas israel i don't even know at this
point what the numbers are but it's very
very high it's got to be approaching
i don't even i mean it's got to be
between 70 and 90 i'm not sure
they've been vaccinating like crazy
that's the explanation
and when tucker carlson you know at this
point i mean
dangerous is an understatement for
tucker carlson's uh rhetoric at this
point in time
the white nationalists are loving what
tucker carlson is doing on his show
including his rant about replacement
earlier this week which we covered
yesterday
uh the anti-vaxxers are loving it um
those against any kovid precautions are
loving it
he is really playing to with his
populist rhetoric
he is actually playing to some of the
worst elements
of american society so the difference is
vaccination
the vaccines work we've only vaccinated
in the 30s percent mid 30s percent of
the american population that's it folks
that's the answer we'll have more about
this on our instagram page find us on
instagram
at david pakman show don't forget that
one of the best
ways to support the david pakman show is
by supporting our sponsors and today
one of those sponsors is sheath
underwear
sheath underwear makes boxer briefs
specifically designed to prevent the
sticking
the rubbing the chafing that many of us
know all too well with traditional
boxer briefs sheath boxer briefs have
multiple ergonomic compartments in the
front
to prevent skin on skin contact keeping
everything separate cool dry and
comfortable
extra helpful now that the weather is
warming up no more sweatiness
no more chafing no more readjusting
sheath underwear is giving the david
pakman show audience 20
off when you go to sheath underwear dot
com slash pacman
use the promo code pacman give sheath
underwear a try i've had a great
experience with it i think you will too
you can find the link right underneath
this video and don't forget
to use promo code pacman for 20
off